ce talent à 314 pourquoi on n'a pas
entendu la la
vous m'entendez
soins intensifs à la 314 on a deux
passions
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là on n'en
sait rien là il faut la mettre sur
robert ses filles au malawi 2 3 on
soulève retient la langue
le bout on en est où il a une colonne et
il a une bonne marge
oui
jeudi matin m il n'est pas l'entrain il
est pas d'entrain il est pas d'entrain
le gars coopté la portière
sens de la marche verte à côté droit
est ce que c'est
on attend
préparez-vous à jeter le sac
premier témoin de libérer les deux
commencez à vous promettre de libérer
les meilleurs
il ya dès que l'on récupère auriez 2
en point d'orgue le train
en voyant ça
quinze secondes selon serait un portail
et une forêt tenez vous prêt à acheter
le sac
je veux d'abord les voies je veux
d'abord et voir elias pu donner à vos
enfants ou non elias vous êtes un grand
malade ça sert à rien vous croire ce que
je vous dis portel
qu'est ce que tu dis le prochain passage
à niveau
2 km
ici à l'école père
proche d'une forêt on va perdre en
visibilité vous allez chanter le sac
dans trois secondes
si vous n'obéissez pas à l'étude
maintenant allez y
alors
on l'a de la police karl marx on
aimerait vous poser quelques questions
d'accord je vous écoute on demande à
tous les habitants de la région s'ils
l'ont pas vu dernièrement quelque chose
d'inhabituel
un témoin a vu quelqu'un forcer un
enfant à monter dans une voiture
on se demande si on pourrait pas trouver
d'autres témoins non j'ai rien vu
vous avez bien des enfants
samuel magdalena ils sont pas ici sous
price ne sont chez chez leur tante en
suède
excusez moi on peut entrer chez vous une
minute on voudrait juge pas la porte aux
étrangers surtout ceux comme mais
surtout ce que ceux qui viennent de la
capitale écoutez nous étions en train de
faire nos prières je répète que j'ai
rien vu
au revoir
quelque chose de pas net